einen bildschirm mit funktionierenden
internetseiten mit allen funktionierte
internetseiten auf der welt inklusive
youtube und youporn und alle möglichen
anderen sachen und ich habe doch ein
ipad junge das ist einfach hey leute und
herzlich willkommen endlich mal wieder
zu einer neuen mod vorstellung und zwar
von dem web displayport beziehungsweise
dem laptop motto bist der laptop mod es
heißt ihr die modifikation und wie
dieser name allerdings schon sagt fügt
diese modifikation einen laptop in das
spiel hinzu das ist so unfassbar geil
als wir haben wirklich einen eigenen
laptop ihr drin wir können hier mit
diesen dingen was sie hier gerade das
ist ein 16 9 bildschirm also wenn ihr
nordrand außen rum bauen wollte musste
er halt dann 18 mal elf sein damit ihr
müsst hat diese zwei blöcke damit ein
berechnen und dann habt ihr wirklich ihr
könnt ihr also keinen richtigen laptop
als ihr habt jetzt nicht hinter der
übelste technik und können damit
minecraft spielen aber ihr könnt damit
halt ins internet und ins internet und
ich zeige euch erst mal wie ihr euch das
ganze hier crafted und zwar brauchte
erstmal oben drei glas pains unten drei
glas pence und dann raus radcliffe
screen und lapislazuli einfach so farben
mäßig und das soll halt so ein bisschen
zu dem bildschirm darstellen dann kriegt
ihr 16 web screens diese 16 web screen
sie packte hier drauf das ist natürlich
mehr als 16 das heißt dem ist das schon
relativ oft machen und ihr müsst davon
halt 16 mal neu machen also 16 09 sind
auf jeden fall über 100 es müssten durch
130 oder so sein
also müsste schon ca weise dich 10 819
mal kraft diese ganze sache hier damit
die genug sachen habt uns spielen
zusammen zu basteln
dann geht ihr einfach auf den screen zu
also ihr seht dass hier bleibt wenn ihr
die zusammen macht ist es wie bei der
glas mod und der macht euch sicherheit
zusammen zu einem dingsbums ihr macht
shift also ihr stiftet euch hier damit
ihr seid euch so häufig dass aus italien
also das ist doch die passenden sitz in
persona vom fernseher bei mir vom
computer äxte zimmer einfach ein
zentimeter davor sich jetzt gerade auch
nicht allerdings in stiftet einfachen
drückt rechtsklick und wir sind einfach
der computer startet und es ist einfach
erst mal weiß jetzt denke ich so was
soll das jetzt wir können jetzt richtig
machen oder links klickt mit links
machen oder kaputt
bringt allerdings nichts wir machen
einfach shift und rechtsklick wieder und
dann können wir hier sehen wir dort
lenkt er kann jeder in dem zb
youtube.com gebe ich mir ein youtube boa
geil also wir sind hier wirklich in die
youtube drin wir haben natürlich werbung
wir können einfach rechts geht drauf
machen schießen wir mal die werbung und
schließt aber schließt es ist halt immer
noch ein bisschen so haben die werbung
jetzt mal geschlossen jetzt können wir
hier zum beispiel mal eingeben
so weiß man was du ja dafür brauchen
keyboard es stimmt natürlich also
keyboard kommt hier noch zu ihr könnt
ihr zum beispiel mal einfach die wieder
drauf klicken auf den bildschirm so mit
shift und rechtsklick dann geht man bei
youtube.com / kontra ftr 1
so und jetzt sind wir auf meinem kanal
wir sehen hier meine top box wir sehen
ja man hat auch thomas kann auch videos
gucken
ich hoffe ganz kurze den den ton im
moment so minuten glauben so ist will
ich dem lied so ihr könnt hier videos
gucken wie es ist ein flash player
installiert das ist so hammer geil
also ich könnte jetzt quasi jedem ein
video gucken und das ist so ziemlich alt
ich bin in minecraft cook einfach mein
video
es hakt zwar so ein ganz klein bisschen
also obwohl es geht eigentlich sogar
doch es geht wirklich noch also man kann
auch vom ton her hörte ich dass man
hey leute und herzlich was hat dazu
getanzt schnee oder nee hab keine angst
oder ihr könnt jetzt hier jedenfalls
meine skandal skandal bei den kanarien
und bisschen runter rutschen können wir
die sachen dann gucken wir haben
megaprojekt also ich mach das gab ihm
einen kanal weil ich daran zu die rechte
haben können sich noch anmelden wir
können auch hier einfach mal so auf
gaming gehen und wir können halt alles
mit rechtzeitig bedienen wir können
schon runter machen wir können hier sind
durch puppen und das geile ist sie denkt
euch jetzt bestimmt audi bei der pge
denkt euch jetzt bestimmt so alle aber
da muss man immer vor dem bildschirm
stehen bleiben sieht durch das hier mal
rein das ist in meinem bett nach
rechtsklick und ich habe die ganzen
sachen einfach auf meinem ipad drauf
ihr denkt jetzt mein paypal von ipad
geklaut ist auch so warte mal wieder
zurück auf meinen kanal hier okay du
machst ja erst mal macht der tornauer
steht auch junge mann streite ich schon
wieder so rum minuten so machen wir hier
war das video an machen dass wir hier so
zac wollen wir mal so obst obst obst
jetzt habe ich das hier bei mir in
meinen körper [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay okay ich bei mir war es gerade so
ich hatte gerade meinen kompletten
bildschirm ist also was ich gemacht habe
ich noch voll bild gemacht dann war
einfach mein bildschirm man meinen ein
bildschirm also mein kompletter
bildschirm nicht nur der minecraft
bildschirm vollbart was passiert wenn
ich jetzt voll gemacht
ja das ist wieder so weit öffnet damit
wirklich youtube sehe ich gerade sonst
im bildschirm kalt ich muss das grabmal
beenden wie kann ich das denn beenden
hier
fick dich also ich kann sogar von
einfach so sind aber wieder zurück auf
der youtube-seite so ganz klien am
anfang also denke ich jetzt zu haye
kommen
ich möchte das mitnehmen und so also
jetzt gehen wieder zurück
krefter jahr so
hier erstmal auf pause damit er uns hier
wieder nicht alles vorschreibt so jetzt
kann es weiter jetzt können einfach das
etikett klick und wir können einfach wir
weiter gucken wir laufen einfach rum
wir laufen damit wir können einfach
nebenbei videos gucken ich könnte
natürlich jetzt auch den ton machen und
so was allerdings wir können einfach mal
weg fliegen und wir sehen das einfach
noch das ist so hammer
wenn ihr zum beispiel irgendwie neues
video hochgeladen sehen von einem
youtuber oder so aber wir wollten den
beiden minecraft sein weil eure maschine
noch laufen soll
und dann geht er einfach in minecraft
und stellt euch neben eure maschine zum
beispiel bewusst stellt euch daneben und
guckt euch einfach hier so das video und
das ist natürlich dann etwas kleiner
aber ich find's einfach viel billiger
wenn man so ein minecraft ist und sich
das angucken keine ahnung ich feiere das
irgendwie richtig
also denkt ihr euch die kraft über sich
in mein bett ist eigentlich relativ easy
also 23 münzten lapislazuli kannte
screen rosetta wieder viel glas pains
verbraucher diesmal nur eins nicht zu
130 sowie bei diesen komischen rap
screentime hier aber was für ein pech
natürlich da sein muss das natürlich
wegen des regens aus
natürlich sollten pc hier dann gibt es
auch noch ein wireless linker der
wireless linker ist dafür da dass das
bild was sich ihr habt halt überall
angezeigt wird also so lange in der
gleichen dimension seit es ist glaub ich
für das mein bett da ich bin mir nicht
ganz genau sich das wird auch sehr sehr
schwammig erklärt die website und den
download lieber in der beschreibung
allerdings wenn ich irgendwo mit meinem
ipad zugriff darauf haben möchte dass
ich dann einfach so eine wireless linker
dabei habe und dass der dann halt immer
so mit dabei ist dass dann auch das neue
ipad funktioniert glaube ich bin ich
allerdings sich sicher das feuer das
linke dann gibt es auch noch ihr könnt
auf eine presidents ins crafting travel
tun dann und dann bekommt der 19 tiefen
dieses don keith müsste mit einem
redstone so verbinden dann bekommt ihr
ein wireless keyboard und dieses
wireless keyboard könnte einfach dahin
selbst darauf zu sehen wir können dazu
rechtzeitig drauf machen allerdings ist
das noch nicht link das heißt man all
die gut aufgepasst haben der aufnahme zu
den bildschirmen
ich habe jetzt viel machen rechtsklick
obst ist es jetzt gelingt
aber soll ich das denn vorhin gemacht
hallo bedingt gelingt das ist nicht
gelingt bay
weil das linke jedoch gelingt hier
spielen selected die kirche stellt jetzt
keyboard hoch presse skeptisch klos ja
so also theoretisch könnte ich nehme ich
jetzt hier draufklicken dann kriegt er
drauf es geht hier zum beispiel die
warte ich mach das mal ein bisschen
damit dass er damit etwas schwächer
sehen weil ich habe etwas eingegeben
allerdings ist war grad echt blöd zum
zeigen weil vorhin hab ich das auf einem
viel fieldings gebracht ich war so auf
dieser höhe ca da kann man das ganz gut
zeigen vor allem youtube ist doof weil
die suche da so ganz oben ist bei google
wäre das gut wir können auch mal zur
abwechslung es gebe auf google so jungs
so google.de so wir sind aktiv auf der
falschen management ea da ist
vorbereitet der cel
allerdings solltet ihr mich allein schon
feiern dafür dass ich so was geiles
vorstelle so konnte auch wenn es
natürlich perfekt haben wir gehen jetzt
hier eine keyboard hin können jetzt
könnte er zu neun ist laut link einmal
weil des link also man jetzt so
rechtsklick rechtsklick so also wir
müssen quasi uhr
wir müssen alleine keyboard hinsetzen
ich zeigt sich jetzt noch mal so langsam
geht man wieder zurück auf google hier
so wir müssen ein keyboard erst mal
hinsetzen dann ein wireless linke auf
keyboard und dann auf den screen und
dann steht das screens elected so wir
können jetzt hier draufklicken keyboard
ok erst auf den screen und dann auf das
keyboard so jetzt steht der link weil
man muss immer zuerst auf den screen und
dann noch das keyboard zum beispiel so
jetzt wissen wir dass auch jetzt habe
ich auch gelernt ich lerne auch aber
noch dazu und jetzt können wir hier
etwas auf das keyboard draufdrücken ist
jetzt natürlich ein bisschen doof
bekommen
wir machen das man einfach so dann
können dass eventuell auch noch sehen
so und jetzt gehen wir ein kontrast dar
so jetzt escape und jetzt haben wir oben
kontraste ein gegeben was kommt als
vorschlag von crafter de ist übrigens
down intro und youtube jetzt kommen wir
hier ein paar videos angucken will
konvertiert zum beispiel einmal auf con
kraft auf facebook gehen dann sehen wir
hier meiner facebook seite zum beispiel
wenn der facebook-seite com kraft als
bei facebook unterwegs natürlich über so
runterscrollen also ein paar post durch
kranke wichtig sind will ich jetzt gar
paphos 10
jetzt denken sie zum beispiel an die
station mit 70.000 mal gucken wir weiter
runter hier hier und hier gehts weiter
na dann mal hier hin zum beispiel zum
beispiel in der firma
wenn jetzt draufklicken netz geladen
bariton aus utah usa wir natürlich
werbung darf ich ihn gucken weil sonst
so jetzt haben wir ein video das können
wir jetzt einfach sagen guck auf einer
facebook page ich weiß nicht ich komme
aber auch nicht auf klar das ist
megageil am geilsten ist natürlich wenn
livestreams auto funktionieren würden
allerdings funktioniert das glaube ich
nicht
ich glaube es ist noch nicht so möglich
es wurden übrigens auch noch sachen
hinzugefügt die mit computer verbinden
kann allerdings muss man muss man dafür
sich erstmal mit computer kraft
auskennen
und das kenne ich echt nicht also wir
gehen jetzt mal leute habt ihr grad
gehört was ich gehört habe livestreams
gehen
also ich hab das echt die mod gesehen
vor einem monat oder so da geht nix da
gab es noch ein keyboard alter wenn das
jetzt geht was ich denke dann wäre es
echt so hammer geil
denn wenn man live streams gucken würde
könnte es müsste eigentlich gehen dass
wir haben ja gerade live stream gesehen
leute anti wie geil das ist ihr könnt
minecraft spielen wenn es das für server
gewalt ist er unglaublich geil die
kommen minecraft spielen ihr stellt euch
da diesem computer hin import nebenbei
was und guckt neben beiden 48 stunden
live stream vom 7
das wäre so heftig alter so schauen wie
es manche an minecraft liga praktisch
tv.com kreft parteien gegeben wenn das
funktioniert alter internet war gut und
es funktioniert einfach alter ich komm
nicht klar auf diesem ort das ist so
heftig das ist einfach die geilste motto
hier entdeckt habe wir können einfach
überall rum surface ist einfach google
chrome für minecraft ist es läuft
einfach richtig bei dieser mod das ist
so heftig wie können auch einfach sachen
eingeben und so was alles das es
hammergeil also diese worte ist einfach
nur feiern
wenn dir die mod genau so verhält wie
ich dann dann schaffen wir eventuell
wollt ihr mehr port vorstellungen dann
schafft mal pro a schaffen wir 5555 hier
52 55 ich weil ich habe euch so ne geile
mode gezeigt
vor allem im schwanz alter die so
hammergeil dahin macht nicht erhalte es
ist so geil
es ist einfach nur habe auch oft kaum
wälder wo es ist so heftig geil
es ist einfach man minecraft es ist
einfach mal ein pc im pc in minecraft es
ist so heftig wie können in minecraft
ins internet gehen das ist daher leute
schreiben immer eine kommentare was er
verbessern würde an dieser modifikation
bz was euch freuen würde und auf welche
seiten jetzt es gehen würde dich welches
handy gehen würde und dann würde ich
sagen schafft man 5500 leicht verstellen
dann sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder